[Music]
you know the jungle it's a part of you
but exploring is not a game and you
don't look before you leap we're onto
something big Dora an ancient city made
of gold but about that and your mother
and I are gonna prove it
Emmy I'm sorry sweetie you're not going
but being in the city around kids your
own age like Diego might help so you're
gonna get invited some of these parties
called rapes the music sounds like this
got it
be careful that's what we want to say
cousin Diego you're so skinny and tough
you are way more energetic than I
remember Dora this isn't the jungle it's
high school it's life or death keep a
low profile
[Music]
and just be cool door okay what is this
[Music]
where did you transfer from the jungle
here's the scavenger hunt list team out
in groups of four hola Dora
you'll help us find your parents and the
lost city of gold where are we
all I see is jungle see three
mercenaries armed
oh look Dora brought a knife on the
field trip everybody who would maybe
want to leave I will with your parents
you're all in danger we're gonna die out
here there's no need to overreact of
course she knows this monkey
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to keep going no matter what
she's freaking awesome this film is not
hydrated
[Music]